appearing in his first All-Star Game
he's the leader of the Boston Celtics
and now head coach of Team Janus Joe
Missoula
[Music]
the head coach of Team LeBron is taking
his second turn on the All-Star Game
Sidelines from the Denver Nuggets
Michael Malone
[Applause]
voted to the starting lineup but injured
and unable to attend are the NBA's
all-time leading three-point shooter and
a four-time NBA champion from the Golden
State Warriors Stefan Curry
foreign
All-Star from the New Orleans Pelicans
Zion Williamson
[Music]
[Applause]
and the two-time NBA champion 13-time
All-Star and a two-time MVP of this
event from the Phoenix Suns KD Kevin
Durham
[Applause]
now let's beat the reserves
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
Ted two-way players a two-time All-Star
representing the Boston Celtics Jalen
Brown
[Applause]
a six-time All-Star from the Chicago
Bulls who is an Undisputed Master of the
mid-range Demar DeRosa
a hardwood hero in the Heartland and a
first-time All-Star he runs the show for
the Indiana Pacers Tyrese Halliburton
[Applause]
make it his eighth All-Star appearance
in 13 Seasons representing the LA
Clippers
PG-13 Paul George
[Applause]
a first little big man who protects the
paint for the Memphis Grizzlies making
his All-Star Game debut tonight Jaren
Jackson Jr
foreign
having one of the best seasons of his
career he's the center of the defense in
South Beach a two-time All-Star from the
Miami Heat bam adebayo
[Applause]
making his second All-Star appearance
and NBA champion at the floor general of
the Milwaukee Bucks Drew holiday
he's the spectacular shooting guard from
the Minnesota Timberwolves making his
All-Star Game debut Ant-Man Anthony
Edwards
thank you
he gets buckets on Broadway in the Big
Apple and is a second time All-Star from
the New York Knicks Julius Randle
[Applause]
taking his game to another level is this
explosive guard in his first All-Star
game from the Oklahoma City Thunder Shea
gilges Alexander
[Applause]
he's a seven-time All-Star and the
all-time leading scorer for the Portland
Trail Blazers it's game time give it up
for Damian Lillard
[Applause]
appearing in his first All-Star Game a
clutch performer who makes his team
light the beam from the Sacramento Kings
dear and fox
[Applause]
he's a versatile big man who Stuffs the
stat sheets making his third All-Star
appearance another king from Sacramento
Del Montes sabonis
a g-league Alum and NBA champion making
his second All-Star appearance from the
Toronto Raptors Pasco siacom
[Applause]
y
and now